Marinette Myrna is with us and in Los
Angeles Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
hi David it's an honor to speak with you
you too what's up well my husband and I
are debt free thanks to you and to have
a fully funded emergency fund but we are
debating what to do next and we could
use your help
my husband is thinking it's better to
pay for a home as you know here on the
west side of LA it's pretty expensive
from it's where all our family live and
you know all our friends and whatnot we
have two small children and some
wondering if it's better for us to keep
renting and just move on to baby step
four and five well if you're going to
buy a home at any point this is the time
to start saving for it we we teach folks
to do what you've done get through baby
step three which is debt free with an
emergency fund and then we call it baby
step three be kind of laughingly that
you say vote for your house before you
start your retirement so but you know I
don't because kind of what you're saying
is is that we'll never get there so
we're going to rent forever and I like
that yeah I just really don't think
that's a good plan rent forever is not a
good plan it's going to be hard I mean
you're in a Los Angeles real estate
market ouch so what's your household
income I'm about 70 ka and it was higher
but I decided to stop working and come
home to view the kids cool that's good
okay so how much guys can you guys save
a year right now we're doing about 300 a
month
um don't pay off we had sixty three
thousand and I got only where you quit
though huh yeah yeah yeah so you can
only save three thousand four thousand
dollars a year right yeah while doing
that yeah and I thought about maybe
working part-time I am a licensed social
worker I think that would be awesome but
maybe even not part-time but maybe just
find something that you can do with your
license from home when the kids are
napping and
for when they're at school or something
like that a lot there's a lot of things
you can do they can generate income to
throw at this house idea I mean just
think about if you save three thousand
dollars a year four thousand dollars a
year now and then you made another even
fifteen thousand and you through all of
that at the house savings program it
changes the whole discussion doesn't it
okay yeah it feels a lot better yeah but
without you I mean but but you have to
design your work idea in such a way that
it doesn't defeat the goal of you coming
home exactly who I am you can do it I
mean there's a lot of stuff you can do
around kids that you can make some good
money doing it's usually some kind of a
self-employed idea is going to be the
best money and so you know if you're
doing some kind of service that your
that your license and your training
allows you to provide for someone that
you can do that you choose the time that
you're doing it exactly then you know
you're controlling the quality of your
life while adding some income to the
equation here which helps you guys to
get forward because then you start
saving fifteen twenty thousand dollars a
year pretty quickly then we start buying
a house and maybe three years or
something that'd be in pretty good shape
now that's if making a $70,000 or with
you making fifteen and eighty five
thousand dollar income that you can
afford a home in that area and I don't
know if you can I mean don't know which
part of LA you have your eyes set on but
you know with the income that you've got
and the choice you've made to be at home
can you afford to live in that area
that's another question you've got to
kind of think through and and you know
it's good to make choices intentionally
but it's also good to accept the
consequences and the results of those
choices and not try to live two lives to
two separate incongruent lives at once